[Music]
have a seat I have good news there's a
ship available the USS Orville ever
since I was a kid I have wanted to serve
on an exploratory vascular nobody's
first choice for this job but we have
3,000 ships to stat and we need captains
and I want these mints those are marbles
we're giving you one last chance I just
want to say I am thrilled to be your new
captain I want this to be an efficient
ship but also one that you're glad to be
serving on lieutenant commander boardís
your entire species is male isn't that
is correct sir
probably not a lot of arguments about
leaving the toilet seat up and that kind
of thing Buckland's urinate only once
per year really that's I mean I'm up to
three times a night but is unfortunate
it is I'm gonna meet the locals hi I'm
captain ed Mercer's holy crap we don't
mean your family any harm what we did to
shooters - aside from shooting your dad
we don't mean your family any harm
captain there's a message coming in from
Admiral Halsey it doesn't an executive
officer it's become available no no no
no no no no no no no sorry man you okay
yeah it's all good man you okay y'all
good sorry
all right no worries the captain does
not appear to be pleased to be arriving
with his first officer they were married
no way you know how many times I tried
to talk to you before here I would want
to suggest a couple therapist was your
brother-in-law it should be really fun
trip for all of us perhaps we should not
be talking about this oh no no we're
talking about this is a thing
you'll be delivering supplies to the
science station on epsilon 2
thank you for coming we need protection
protection from what the krill we have
figured out a way to manipulate the
speed of events so it's an anti banana
ray it's really interesting we need no
longer fear the banana does it work on
offers about salads you do realize this
to be used as a weapon that's why you're
here order the captain Murphy just
affected a krill destroyer entering
orbit
newer student flora can open this jar of
pickles for me I loosened it for you
return fire
give me the divine or I will destroy
your ship sorry you can move like two
steps to your right it's just a lot of
dead space there just perfect gasps are
you were just very weirdly frame Oh what
is that a beer damn nervous you know
it's a new ship want to make a good
impression
it's 9:15 in the morning sorry
[Music]
you